[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
if I
had I
[Music]
draw
heav
don't you push me
[Music]
baby cuz I'm all
alone don't you know only in it for the
[Music]
go all that I'm asking
for
10 gold
[Music]
doll I could pay
you long good
[Music]
hand you can look around
about the whole world
[Music]
over you'll never find another honest
man
Fair the
[Music]
country
there in the
town your go
dollar where your love
is
baby for I let my he go
[Music]
down
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
last
we in the
[Music]
country as real
in the
town but you
go with he your love
is
baby for I I will go
[Music]
down
don't you push me
[Music]
baby
alone I might know something that you
might never
[Music]
know don't you drink a
lior just a cup
cold
[Music]
coffee when I wake
up in the
morning let
[Music]
know
everybody's
dragging
drinking that
wine
I can see the queen Diamond by the way
she
shine
come to
Pap on an inside
stength well I got no chance of
losing this
time I have no chance to
lose this
[Music]
time